[Música]
yo recuerdo que cuando yo estaba en esta
misma universidad cuando estaba
terminando mi carrera se me acercó mi
tío emitido por cierto está acá
y me dijo mi hijo tengo un problema
me están incumpliendo un contrato
y quisiera acudir a la justicia
y en esa época
pues había visto toda la teoría y estaba
aquí en la universidad pero no tenía
mucho de la práctica
y lo que vine a ver o lo que yo me
imaginaba como un pichón de abogada
idealista era un poco esto era la serie
norteamericana no a las uts un saco y
corbata haciendo un argumento
interesantísimo y la verdad lo que me
terminé encontrando fue
arrumes y arrumes de papel atados con
capucha como lo harían en 1800 y donde
había que hacer
poderes memoriales demandas
contestaciones recursos
esta historia comenzó en el año 2006
estamos en el año 2018 y el caso de mi
tío aún no se ha resuelto
la última vez que hablábamos me decía no
sé si valió la pena no sé si todo este
desgaste todo esos años tú este estrés
tenían algún sentido y yo quisiera que
te necesitamos acá y quienes han
compartido un poco esta situación como
la de mi tío levantaron la mano quienes
por cartera porque es largo porque es
costoso han dejado de acudir a la
justicia pueden levantar la mano quien
lo ha dejado de hacer
una buena mayoría y yo creo que es que
los que son chiquitos todavía no han
tenido que ir
pues bien
y ustedes no están solos
como ustedes hay cuatro mil millones de
personas en el mundo
esto lo dice naciones unidas'
pero para que lo vean un poquitico más
gráficamente esto es como si todo el
continente americano toda europa toda
áfrica toda oceanía y toda la china en
el mundo no tuvieran acceso a la
justicia
y en colombia la situación es un poco
más dramática porque esta falta de
acceso a la justicia nos lleva a cifras
comprobadas por el ministerio de
justicia a que 3 de cada 10 personas
prefieren recurrir a la venganza que al
sistema judicial para resolver sus
conflictos sus controversias la ley del
ojo por ojo sigue siendo el día a día de
nuestra justicia por mano propia
y esto llevaba percepciones la
percepción ciudadana y que ha sido
recogida por el world justice proyect
nos dice tres cosas la primera es que la
justicia es lenta muy lenta
según el reporte del banco mundial del
doing bussiness
el país que va más avanzado es corea del
sur y colombia entre 190 países medidos
es el número 177
en la efectividad de su sistema judicial
cerca de nosotros están otros países
latinoamericanos como uruguay república
dominicana
brasil por ejemplo si él está en una
situación dramática 80 con millones de
procesos sin solución
lo segundo que nos dice la percepción
ciudadana es que la justicia es muy
costosa
según también el banco mundial nos
cuesta a nosotros casi el 46 por ciento
de lo que estamos reclamando acudir a la
justicia
es decir que si yo quisiera reclamarle
10 millones de pesos al sistema judicial
yo me gasto más o menos 4 millones 580
mil pesos en abogados en papeles en
poderes en notarías
y en tercer lugar
la justicia a nosotros como ciudadanos
percibimos la justicia con muy
formalista nosotros seguimos con
formalismos del derecho romano
fíjense por ejemplo el caso colombiano
que es bastante dramático nosotros
cuando tenemos una reclamación la
llevamos
en primera instancia un juzgado aquí en
la décima no en morales molina la
pelamos tribunal superior de bogotá no
estamos de acuerdo vamos en casación a
la corte suprema no estamos de acuerdo
tutela en primera instancia ante otros
jueces estamos de acuerdo
apelamos y en última instancia puede
terminar en la corte constitucional
seis pasos
no en vano hay un dicho común entre
abogados es que la vida útil de un
abogado es un proceso ordinario es decir
más o menos 20 años y tenemos en el
consejo de estado- casos que empezaron
en el año 90 si podemos estar hablando
de 28 años un proceso en colombia sin
definirse
en una palabra nuestro sistema judicial
es ineficaz
y esa fue una inquietud que yo siempre
me lleve desde que estaba en la
universidad y a lo largo de mi carrera
profesional fui madurando este tema y un
día
cuando trabajaba en el ministerio de
justicia hace ya seis años siendo
perfectamente productivo haciendo mis
deberes estaba metido en facebook
y en facebook
me salió un anuncio y el anuncio decía
george punto me juzga me
y lo hicieron y eso que es me causa
mucha curiosidad cuando le di click lo
que me explicaba era que uno podía
resolver una controversia enteramente en
línea a través de la internet
y lo que me sol y entonces me pareció
interesante influencia cómo puedo
salirme de esto estarlo en el papel y
hacerlo todo en línea mucho más
conveniente y empecé a investigar sobre
el tema
francamente me enamoré de la idea y me
encontré con que eso no era nada nuevo
desde los años 90 desde casi el mismo
inicio de la internet se empezaron a
promover mecanismos de solución de
controversias en línea ebay por darles
un ejemplo resolvió más de 80 millones
de controversias enteramente en línea es
decir que si yo tengo un problema y
estoy vendiendo un producto a través de
la plataforma de ebay no hay otros
grandes ser bien vi o alibaba cuando yo
tengo esta controversia la puedo llevar
directamente
en el sistema y el sistema me la va a
ayudar a resolver
pues bien
desde ese momento entonces le empecé a
trabajar mucho yo le hablé con un grupo
de personas y le dije ministro este es
el futuro de la justicia tenemos que
hacer algo y empezamos a hacer un grupo
y el grupo estuvo conformado por gente
del gobierno por gente de la academia
incluida esta universidad y por
entidades multilaterales y me llegaron
algún momento de naciones unidas a
hablar de este tema
y por cierto pues ese yo nunca ningún
discurso en naciones unidas esto fue
sólo una foto para redes sociales
pero lo que sí me dejó esa experiencia
de seis años puede trabajar en un
reglamento y en una plataforma para que
podamos hacer esto en colombia y en eso
venimos trabajando en los últimos seis
años y hace apenas unos meses en julio
logramos que fuera aprobado
y en qué consiste
en el caso de mi tío por ejemplo se
metió tuviera su controversia él podría
abrir un usuario
un usuario como lo haría en facebook y
llevaría su reclamación o su demanda
también directamente en línea todos los
documentos todas las pruebas irían a
esta plataforma electrónica y la empresa
a la que emitió estaría demandado
también contestaría por este medio
comunicaciones a través de correo
electrónico
primero entramos a una negociación
automatizada que las partes puedan en lo
posible solucionar sus controversias en
el caso de ebay funciona para el 80% de
los casos
pero si eso no es posible lo que
proponemos en esta plataforma es que se
pueda nombrar un árbitro online un
árbitro es básicamente un juez privado
un juez al que yo le pago para que me
resuelva la controversia y este árbitro
resolvería el caso dos meses en
principio
ya estaríamos pasando de 20 años a 2
meses que está bastante bien
sin embargo hay perros
siempre ahora pero si yo me acuerdo que
cuando empecé a hablar de este tema
con las personas con las que les
menciona me hablaban tú y tú arbitraje
online como la propaganda es usted
porque habla esto esto no sirve nuestro
sistema judicial es el que debería
funcionar
el primer pero que se decía es que uno
esperaría que el juez estuviera presente
que el juez pudiera ver a los abogados
pudiera interactuar con los testigos eso
es lo que nosotros los abogados llamamos
la inmediaciones
y que por eso un sistema de justicia
online no sería efectivo
pues bien
si nosotros podemos llevar algo tan
íntimo como nuestras relaciones
sentimentales a través de aplicativos
como tender y por cierto que nos dé la
foto sello
si podemos llevar algo tan íntimo y tan
personal como una relación a través de
un aplicativo online porque no podemos
llevar un sistema un servicio público
esencial como es la justicia
el segundo pero el sacrosanto principio
del debido proceso ya nosotros los
abogados desde que estamos en la
universidad primer año nos dicen es que
hay que respetar unos pasos procesales
uno detrás del otro y que el respeto
esto estos pasos es lo que garantiza que
se haga justicia verdadera
el proceso nos ayuda absurdos como que
en inglaterra por ley para acudir a una
corte tanto abogados como jueces deben
llevar peluca blanca eso hace parte del
debido proceso
lo que yo creo que nos ayuda este
sistema es a lo siguiente y es que las
reglas en un sistema en un sistema de
justicia online están auto contenidas
así las llama richard süskind que es uno
de los grandes visionarios del derecho y
él dice que un sistema como estos nos
ayuda a nosotros a seguir el paso a paso
del debido proceso pero que el algoritmo
se encarga de que los pasos se cumplan y
eso puede ser mucho mejor que un mes
arbitrario que quiera saltarse los pasos
otro punto como el de los niños de acá y
es
todas las personas entonces podrían
tener acceso a la justicia online no
estaremos discriminando a los menos
favorecidos
estoy un par de datos
hay más de 4000 21 millones de personas
en el mundo que ya tienen acceso al
internet se acordaban de esa primera
cifra de los 4000 que no tienen acceso a
la justicia hagan las cuentas
en colombia 63% de las personas ya
tienen acceso al internet y esto es
mucho mejor que el 80 por ciento de las
personas que deciden no acceder al
sistema judicial porque como los que
levantaron la mano les parece que no
vale la pena
el tercer pero este sistema es costoso
si yo voy a utilizar la justicia online
voy a tener que pagar por ella
pues esto no es nuevo y como ya les
venía mencionando ha podido bajar los
costos para que cuando haya la
intervención de un ser humano un
intermediario un mediador en este caso
se paguen tan sólo 15 dólares
mucho menos de los 4 millones más o
menos de lo que yo les estaba hablando
antes
como lo hablábamos con el mensajero que
trabaja en la oficina en la que yo esté
vinculado el otro día y es si yo tengo
plata para pagar netflix porque no voy a
tener plata para arreglar mi conflicto
por último el cuarto pero es que a veces
se habla de un sistema sesgado en el
caso de ebay o derby se dice que el
sistema está diseñado de tal manera que
se favorezca a los consumidores
pues bien el reglamento colombiano y la
plataforma colombiana responden a esa
inquietud y no hacer un sistema que
pertenezca a la misma empresa sino que
por el contrario va a ser un sistema que
va a ser dado por un tercero por ejemplo
una cámara de comercio en ese sentido el
árbitro que ese nombre no va a tener
vinculación directa con la empresa sino
que nos va a ayudar un tercero a
solucionar
está en el ring
pero
apenas comienza
en australia si es un sistema que se
llama el split o el spirit top es que
cuando una pareja está en divorcio y
están haciendo la división de bienes con
la ayuda de un algoritmo el algoritmo
les ayuda a identificar cuáles son los
bienes que le deberían corresponder a
cada una de las personas que se va a
separar
y fíjense que cuando están sentadas a la
mesa podría por celos o por las
dificultades que pudo tener el
matrimonio no estarían tan dispuestas a
decir no le voy a dar este bien no
prefiero así a mi esposa le gusta el
carro yo prefiero que no se lo quede
el algoritmo hacia la escogencia mejor
por ellos y hace que se llegue a una
justicia una negociación mucho mejor
lograda a partir de la utilización de la
tecnología luego no sólo nos solucionar
las controversias sino que nos hace
tomar decisiones más audaces y
decisiones que son más convenientes
por otra parte
en materia de resolución de
controversias está el y george eligió en
temas de la corte europea de derechos
humanos que nuevos son temas sensibles
pudo predecir con un 79 por ciento de
fiabilidad cuál era la decisión que iba
a tomar la corte europea con unos casos
dados lo que se hicieron es que
alimentar una base de datos se la
presentaron al algoritmo y cuando le
presentaron un caso nuevo la base de
datos y el algoritmo pudieron predecir
con mucha mayor precisión que la de
muchos jueces y la de muchos abogados
cuál iba a ser el resultado
entonces pues con todo esto un mundo sin
abogados creería uno
pues yo creo que no lo que hacen estos
mecanismos es darle acceso a muchas más
personas que tengan posibilidad de
resolver sus conflictos y al hacerlo los
abogados seremos facilitadores
probablemente no cobremos tanto pero
podremos cobrar en volumen y podremos
ayudarle a muchas más personas
pero otro temor terminator con toga
entonces ahora las máquinas van a
decidir por nosotros
pues yo creo que no
con un sistema de justicia online lo que
estamos logrando es una verdadera
convergencia entre la tecnología y la
capacidad humana
piense que un sistema de éstos
permitiría que por ejemplo el caso de mi
tío no fuera 20 años sino apenas 20
minutos
y lo que estamos permitiendo es que el
sistema nos ayude a nosotros a tomar
mejores decisiones de manera que la
justicia se haga cada vez más justa y
más accesible
y por eso yo creo que nunca como hasta
ahora la justicia había estado en la
palma de nuestras manos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]